sally thank you turning to politics now
tomorrow is the first day of the
democratic national convention
where joe biden will formally accept the
party's nomination for president
but due to the coronavirus it will all
be virtual
orco mana joins us live now in the
newsroom with a breakdown of what we can
expect
orko well sasha the democratic national
convention was supposed to take place
in person in milwaukee but everything
has shifted online in the wake of
covid19
still the convention is taking place and
a few local leaders
will have some time in the spotlight the
convention kicks off tomorrow
and will feature four nights of speakers
that includes u.s senator catherine
cortez masto from nevada who will speak
on night one
and nevada state senator havana cancella
all speakers will appear remotely and
joe biden will accept the nomination
from his home state of delaware nevada
democrats are planning a series of
online watch parties
throughout the week and tell me an
upside to a virtual convention
is that it's more accessible to everyone
our goal within the party is to make
sure that we have as many nevada
democrats as possible participating
um and also it's important for them to
understand what's exactly at stake
in this election a trump campaign
spokesperson tells me quote
the dnc convention convenes this week
nevadans will see the far left socialist
policies
that make joe biden and kamala harris
the most extreme ticket in history
president trump will continue to put
america first
again the democratic national convention
begins tomorrow
and continues through august 20th the
republican national convention is set to
take place
next week sasha